welcome back to new rockstars hayden
christensen
is returning as darth vader anakin
skywalker in the upcoming
obi-wan kenobi series on disney plus
alongside hello there you and mcgregor
if you told me this two weeks ago i
would have said to you
liar but uh hungry to redeem his return
of the jedi
force ghost cameo now that fans don't
entirely hate his character after clone
wars
the man is back to all of acting it
seems cause he
has been mia while he is back in our
lives
i'm eric boss this is rogue theory the
show that brings you the wildest nerdy
hot takes on the topics we can't stop
arguing about with me to go rogue today
is a brother in this grand crusade of
easter egg breakdowns
the really only other youtube nerdy
analyzer i can truly trust with this
stuff
unless he's about to hit me with another
one of those it's your mom jokes
from screen crush ryan airy welcome to
new rockstars ryan thanks eric good to
be here
also here with us is friend of the show
comedy writer and host of the crush
fictionally podcast
kim trung welcome back kim what's up
homies
what's up and i am also happy to welcome
first time here on do rockstars
friend of the show and comedian back
from our old days at i o west r.i.p
in hollywood kristen sanchez welcome
kristen hi
hi that's me i'm so excited to be here
yay
we're so excited to have you all right
let's dive into the big news folks
among the tidal wave of marvel and star
wars news that came out last week at
disney investor day the biggest star
wars news
was that hayden christensen is going to
reprise his role as anakin skywalker in
the upcoming obi-wan kenobi series
on disney plus now uh we know obi-wan
invader back from the very first star
wars film they dueled in
uh their big fight on the death star in
a new hope
and in that movie you'll remember darth
vader seemed to sense obi-wan nearby he
says it's a prison so i have not felt
since
and then he trailed off allowing our
nerd minds to fill in what that
backstory was
but then uh revenge of the sith did it
for us there was the epic battle on
mustafar that left anakin
horribly burned and injured right joe
uh obi-wan had the high ground and boy
did he use it he
ended up taking the blue lightsaber to
one day give to
uh vader's son luke now we have got some
flashes of what vader was up to in those
in between years
uh at the end of clone wars we found out
that he was seeking out ahsoka found
what looks like her grave and then he
did later battle with ahsoka
chronologically we saw that in rebels
uh in rogue one we saw how he wrecked
rebel soldiers during the battle scarif
and uh now by bringing back vader in
this kenobi series it is being implied
that these two men had other collisions
during that gap period
so i want to know from you three i want
to hear uh
what went down between darth vader and
obi-wan kenobi during
the age of the empire and what do you
think hayden christensen will look like
in this series um ryan why don't we
start with you
like you said vader says i haven't felt
the presence in and he never quite says
when so it's not necessarily
their last encounter was not necessarily
revenge of the sith except he does say
the last time we met i was the learner
and you were the master so it implies
that right
i think is going to happen is obi-wan is
on tatooine we know a little bit about
what he's done on tatooine from
the the comic book the new marvel comic
series
uh i don't want to spoil anything but he
has some like brief interrupt
interactions with the lars family and
the tuscan raiders
so i think he's on tatooine he knows
luke is safe and
vader is going around the galaxy at this
point according to the comics but he's
not
like people don't know the name darth
vader you know in rebels when he shows
up kanan and ezra are like what was that
they don't even understand that it's a
human being inside of there so i think
that
ob1 somehow or another gets wind of a
darth vader and in revenge of the sith
if you'll remember he hears the emperor
in the hologram
call anakin lord vader so he know and he
says you know send me to kill the
emperor and all this
so he knows who darth vader is he just
thinks that darth vader's dead and he
died on the rock so i think if he
heard wind of a darth vader somewhere or
another he would go oh i didn't finish
the job
and so then it's going to be him leaving
the planet to go off and find him
now as for what anakin's going to look
like i think that hayden christensen is
going to be the man in suit
like he was at the end of revenge of the
sith which i'm not
that happy with because i think you can
definitely tell
that it's hayden christensen in the suit
and not like a massive bodybuilder
but also one thing i would love to see
and
uh is if we do see glimpses of child
luke
in return of the jedi when luke talks to
leia he's you know he has this distant
look in his eye and says i have no
memory of my mother
which implies that he had some memory or
some vision of his father
so i'm wondering just like leia talked
about oh my mother was very pretty
if she dreamed about padme maybe baby
luke or 10 year old luke has dreams
about his father
and he sees his father's face not
necessarily as a jedi
but through the force he's able to kind
of connect with him because
later in jedi he seems very certain
all out of nowhere out of the blue that
there's good in his father
and maybe these dreams are what kind of
led him
to that to having that feeling of
connection with his dad
and then we'd kind of get to see anakin
interact with luke which would be cool
that
is really cool i love the idea of luke
dreaming of his father
um and and having that kind of a destiny
calling to him like when he's looking at
the the twin sons of uh
the binary sunset really what he's
connecting with
is like you know the the father and son
like his his dad
in that moment uh and he just maybe
doesn't fully know what it means yet
that that's pretty cool uh so do you
think we're never gonna see hayden's
face is it just gonna be
uh like we gotta see his face otherwise
they wouldn't get hayden to do it are
we gonna have james earl jones doing the
voice again like how's it gonna look
there i kind of think you have to have
james earl jones doing the voice yeah i
mean there's so many
we can see him you know back to tank his
meditation chamber
um clone wars flashbacks honestly i
think are the most likely
you know to see him and ellen mcgregor
again i get flashbacks things like that
even though
it's been 15 years but i mean no
mcgregor looks great i assume hayden
christensen does i haven't seen
like you said he hasn't been in public
he hasn't shown his face
since shattered glass so i don't know
yeah the it's so interesting
that they were able to convince them to
come back and like hayden christensen's
like look this is what people know me at
so uh i you know have kids who want to
go to college some days
oh totally i feel like it's
it's almost like a david arquette moment
where like david arquette like won the
championship and like totally like
uh under did like the entirety of that
belt and then he came back and like
earned
the wrestlers like cried again because
he like cared about it so much and he
was like
no i'm gonna do this and then he really
did it and now everyone freaking loves
him like
this is like the the the hero's journey
of hayden if you would
and i love that your monomyth is david
arquette in the wrestler movie
that's so great are you talking about
ready to are you talking about ready to
rumble
okay so yes that did happen but
real quick david arquette like won a
championship
and everyone in the wrestling community
was like real real upset about it and
then after that
he like decided that he was going to
like like make sure that everyone
respected him
by actually going in and taking
wrestling very seriously and he became
like a real wrestler and he goes around
and he wrestles
and like the fans freaking love him now
because he like actually took it
seriously
and i think that's what he's doing i
love that and you know i was gonna say
like oh people are here for
for uh darth vader news but there most
of these fans are like yes
finally someone brought up brought up
david our cat's wrestling history
please someone's talking about david
arquette
well ryan i love your your take this
whole idea of uh bringing in a young
luke in this series too
um and flashing back to uh memories of a
live action clone wars adventures that'd
be really really cool so i'm gonna give
you
uh two points for your theory two points
for you
thank you is that good that's my first
time here i don't know like
yeah yeah usually we stay in the single
digits um because i would have tried
harder
if i'd known we were keeping score oh
everything is scored here on rogue
theory
the scores usually don't matter at the
end but you can read the credits of
whose line is it anyway that's usually
your reward
dan patterson uh and i'm doing bits yeah
i weirdly remember that dan patterson is
the executive producer of who's line
[Laughter]
because
yeah all right uh but i want to hear
some alternate takes of what this kenobi
uh darth vader backstory is gonna be so
uh kim
why don't you go next how do you think
this is gonna look i hate to disappoint
you but i actually think i'm very
similar my theory is very similar to
ryan
there might be something to it then the
difference between ryan and
my my theory is that um ryan
i think you had mentioned that obi-wan
senses
darth vader out there and uh
for me i think the calling will be
obi-wan coming across luke in some
capacity
and seeing the innocence in luke in this
child
and remembering the innocence of what
anakin was when he was a kid and he was
a boy
and that's the fire in him as his last
last ultimate bold italic underlying
ditch effort to try to get anakin back
because
there is some good as we see that luke
clearly sees in his father left in darth
vader and i think this is his last ditch
effort before
we move on into um the next trilogy wow
okay so you
think uh obi-wan is there's it's like a
redemption
effort like he's like you know what we
battled on mustafar
he seemed pretty pissed but even as
vader there's still hope to try to bring
him back
i mean what do you think he's going to
try to do is it like he's going to try
to kidnap him and like scare him
straight
like how how would one go about doing
that to darth vader
is it lame to say uh that i think
there's going to be
telepathy involved right where we don't
necessarily see them in person
in the same vicinity or room for quite
some time until i guess
the ultimate duo that they keep talking
about that is going to happen again
between darth vader and obi-wan so
i'm going to assume that it may be like
kind of like the mandalorian where the
overarching goal
for mando is to get the child back with
his people
but it's not the the main action of
every episode right so i think that's
going to be the overarching goal as
obi-wan trying to get
through to anakin i don't know how it
will happen but i think there is going
to be
that telepathy involved where they
somehow can sense each other and there's
blips of conversation that happens and
we ultimately i don't know maybe it
ultimately comes down to
some battle somewhere i don't know i i'm
not the person to be paid to come up
with these theories but i think
that's ultimately how it's going to
happen
is that i mean you do tap into
um this idea of like if it is a psychic
battle that kind of gives us a way
forward of how they can
why they want hayden christensen to do
this because like that's a big challenge
he has become darth vader now they put
the mask on his face in revenge of the
sith
like yeah we can see him in the back to
tank but they're gonna have to come up
with some way if they want hayden
christensen to do it
like and if it is just like a mental
projection kind of thing like uh
the way we saw those force-time chats
and last jedi and rise of skywalker
um if his his projected form
is his anakin form is hayden christensen
that is cool if we could see like
psychic mind battles between the two of
them
but it is just hayden versus like you
know you in
in in that fight then we can still keep
a
corporeal form of darth vader in the
mask and nothing gets changed there but
it's just like he's trying to reach out
to his anakin essence
and that is a telepathic battle as you
said yeah and i
i think that leads right into your next
question which is what is he going to
look like i think there it's going to be
both i think we're gonna see a little
bit of both somehow like i think they're
why bring back hayden christensen to get
into a darth vader suit i
just i can't imagine that's the only
form we're gonna see him in
again me thinking like a disney
executive i know people get mad for me
putting on my disney business hat but i
think that
there's a reason why they're bringing
back hayden christensen i feel like that
that's not to be ignored i think that's
that's an a very viable
uh alternative that i think is
interesting i'd love to see flashbacks
recreations of episodes of the clone
wars and live action
i'd also love to see a trippy ass mind
battle
i mean we talked about in a recent
episode of the mandalorian those
butterflies right and how they could
connect to that darth vader comic where
there's like blue butterflies that
represented the goodness
but like what's really cool about that
comic is you see vader
in his like savage mind's eye depiction
of himself where he's just like
red and bloody and veiny but then like
this white
silhouette that's just like what the
[ __ ] are we looking at
um but if we get to see a version of
that
and it's freaking fiery hayden in
as like this like uh fighting a demonic
version of himself
like yeah show me that
insanity i want to see this i want to
see that [ __ ] too
take my money for force awakens they
were gonna do that they were talking
about having hayden christensen back and
they actually had concept art of him
like as a force vision where he's half
vader and half anakin
and i mean that that would look awesome
yeah
i do remember that that would have been
really sick maybe that's what they're
doing maybe
ryan he might have found the old file
you know the old ark of the covenant and
the uh
lucasfilm archives to show us what
they're gonna do
hold on um so uh i am going to give
uh i'm gonna give two points uh to kim
uh one point for uh her theory on what
they're gonna do with it another point
for this
telepathic visual but i'm gonna give
another point to ryan for uh for that
old
concept
kristin it is your turn how do you think
this is going to look in this kenobi
series all right i'm really excited
about this go with me here
okay so we're getting we're getting a
big
battle that is what we have been
promised as fans and that's the moment
that i really want to get into
okay so we are at the height of vader
evil at this moment like the height of
it because he's like
he's killed the younglings he's on his
own he's exploring the galaxy with all
of his evil powers
and one of the things that he's doing is
going over to geonosis
and he goes over to geonosis and he
kills
everyone because they're secretly
building
they're secretly building the death star
in genoci in space and they can't let
anyone know they can't let anyone know
that
so it's totally fine i can't let anyone
know so because they can't let anyone
know it's there
vader uh is going to be there and he's
obviously going to be doing all the
killing
and there's going to be a great
disturbance in the force
and obi-wan is going to feel it on
tatooine and he's going to
get his butt over to geonosis a place
that he's been to before
and he's going to have a moment where
he's going to actually
battle vader and it is going to be
another moment as you mentioned before
ryan where he's going to be
uh the student because uh like when we
see
uh obi-wan the next time he's not like
injured he's not like
maimed he's totally good to go and like
you know
he's got to win that second lightsaber
battle so that when vader
wins eventually in the third lightsaber
battle that they have
then it's like ah did he really win or
did kenobi
actually win so like he's actually
winning all three battles but yeah so
that's where i'm going that's what i
think is happening that's how we're
gonna have that interaction with those
two
and that's how we're gonna get that
super cool battle
that's where i'm thinking that's where
i'm going because like the cool part
about that is like also you get that
moment
where like kenobi says like that like
that is no moon
and like because we could have that
moment where all of a sudden
he just sees the death star and it's not
like completely built yet
so it's just partially built and and so
like he sees it
but he doesn't know what it is because
there's never been a death star before
but he could be like hmm what is this
thing maybe it's just a giant space
station like the biggest one i've ever
seen
so that's why he's like there that is no
moon in
a new hope you know kristen that is a
really cool theory i love tying
in the creation of the death star
project stardust um
and i really want to see the early days
of that you know
anytime we watch the prequels and they
had that death star show up on screen
i'm like ooh give me more that like i
want to know
yummy yummy i want more yeah the the bad
batch series
we're talking about could explore you
know tarkin and krennic
and some of that uh uh galen urso i i
want to explore the early days of the
empire and this could explode in live
action
uh because uh our next topic we're gonna
talk about is gonna explore the the some
of the
waning days of the empire leading up to
battle of the avent but um
but yeah so what do you think um uh
hayden christensen is gonna look like in
the series are they just bringing them
back
to redo some of those store some of
those sword fighting stunts
from uh the battle on mustafar or is it
gonna take a different form
okay so i love hayden i love it i love
him from the bottom of my heart i had
the biggest crush on him
huge i know he could he could make
no wrong decisions but hayden
is not the best factor but like he's so
great and he's such a nice guy like he's
so
so great but like maybe if he didn't
react that wouldn't be the end of the
world
so like i mean it would be awesome if we
had him
but it's still james earl jones so james
jones still gets to make all those like
yummy decisions whenever he's like
talking and he's like um darth vader you
know
like he is and it's super cool and we
get that but
we also get hayden in the suit and he's
happy and like
that's great because he's back and the
fans wanted to be back and he gets to be
in the series again
and that's super cool but like maybe
it's like one of those things where like
contractually we only see his like face
ever like once a season
like we kind of do in the mandalorian
and it's just like
maybe like we just get like one shot in
a back to tank
or like we get one shot of him like
meditating and like doing his thing
and then it's right back into that
helmet because no no choices for acting
for you
you're very very sweet we love you
enough but you can't do that
look uh we did not get to see a lot of
great performances from him in those two
films i agree but hey you know who also
also looks bad is natalie portman in
those movies and she's a great actress i
think it was the writing
i think it's a dialogue writing yeah
yeah
yeah because what dialogue was real real
rough for them
but like again i want to see him come
back i want him to be i want him to be
exactly what we wanted him to be in that
franchise from the beginning i want to
see it all i want to see him come back
the hero's journey is not just for
skywalker
it is also for christensen yeah yeah the
rise of christensen
um yes just showing them in the back to
tank would be fun if like
they're just like we're going to put you
in a jacuzzi for you know a couple
months
or we'll take you out every now and then
so you don't get too pruned and the
other thing that i think would be real
cool
is seeing hayden in full like gore
makeup again because that was
super cool we only got to see it for
like a short period of time
but like could you imagine the makeup
artist being told like
hey what's up you get to go make him
into like a crispy critter and they're
like
that'd be super cool yeah if you look
gross like
not just the ah like the red eyes that
he had but like
when he was on that gurney as the thing
was coming down on his face and he just
looked
a little potato totally
if that's just today that we get
freaking cool
yeah a little gooey gooey just a little
gooey yeah
i prefer crispy critter as a description
for his makeup kristen the points i was
gonna lie to you fluctuate is a bit of a
roller coaster for me there i gotta say
you started at two
uh you went up to three with the death
star uh aid the visual aid
then you went back down to one uh for
saying that he would have to be in the
helmet the whole time
and that his voice would have to be
covered by uh james earl jones the whole
time like well then why bring in hayden
at all but
by saying that he's good to be in makeup
well james
is great but you gotta give hayden
something to do but
to give him this sense of he could be in
gnarly gooey makeup
that i do want to see that that would be
a pretty cool yeah to
give him something to do there um so
you've come back you've averaged out at
two points two points for kristen whoa
we have a lot of good takes i mean so
much of the big question on this is what
is hayden gonna look like that's why i
want to explore it so much i think
that's gonna be the curiosity
don't show us in trailers lucasfilm
leave that for
whatever episode he comes in i want that
to be the big reveal i don't
because you know it's gonna be like
sonic you show him in trailers people
are gonna
pull it apart just kind of bring it in
on the show
you spend all the time you need
rendering those vfx until it
looks great um don't don't rush it do
not rush this
trust me all right we're gonna go rogue
on some other star wars news
in a bit first i want to thank some
people who helped us make this episode
first we want to thank our friends at
bespoke post for helping make this
episode so the curators at bespoke post
have done it again this winter with an
all new lineup of essential box of
awesome collections for guys guaranteed
to upgrade your life
i have enjoyed the antipasti box which
came out with
all the fixings for a really delicious
uh charcuterie board i was in sausage
heaven
hey i didn't write that line zack wrote
that oh
zach he's always working in his his
weird puns
but whether it's showcase pieces to lift
up your indoor
hosting skills or cozy threads for those
blustery days bespoke post
only sends guys the best stuff every
month no matter what you are into box of
awesome has you covered
from style and grooming goods to bar
ware cooking tools and outdoor gear
box of awesome has collections for every
part of your life a current box that
looks really cool is the flame box with
a
miniature indoor fireplace i bet that is
real cozy on a cold winter night we
don't get too many of them here in los
angeles but
i've been told winter is something very
different the rest of the world
now to get started take the quiz at box
of awesome.com your answers will help
them pick the right box of awesome for
you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up
and you can skip a month or cancel any
time each box costs 45 bucks but
has over 70 dollars worth of gear inside
it
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome.com
and enter the code rogue checkout that's
r-o-g-u-e
not rouge rogue uh that's box of awesome
dot com
code rogue for 20 off your verse box
we also want to thank our friends at
blue chew
fellas do you remember the days when you
were ready to go well now you can get
back that extra confidence
in bed from our friends at bluechew.com
it's blue like the color blue bluetooth
brings you the
first chewable with the same
fda approved active ingredients as
viagra in dialys
you can take them anytime day or night
so you can be ready whenever an
opportunity arises hey
um blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed physicians so you don't have to
go to the doctor's office or wait in
line the pharmacy
it ships right to your door in a
discreet package but why be discreet i
mean once you get this blue chew you're
going to want to scream
at all your neighbors be like i'm going
to get a boner now
thanks blue chew you should be proud of
it well
no actually don't be proud of your
boners don't go outside walking around
with these things that's
assault brother bluetooth is made in the
usa and
since bluetooth repairs and ships direct
they are cheaper than a pharmacy also
there's no awkwardness and no
leaving the house you don't have to you
know slam your piss on that pharmacist
uh plexiglass be like stop giving people
the modern vaccine and give me my boner
pills
that awkward situation's gone you can
just get
a yummy chewable delivered right near
your door isn't that awesome
and right now we've got a special deal
for our listeners visit
bluechew.com and get your first shipment
for free when you use our special promo
code rogue
just pay five dollars in shipping that
again is b-l-u-e
chew dot-com promo code rogue to try it
for free
blue chew is the better cheaper choice
and remember when you support our
sponsors you help make this show
possible so please be sure to use our
promo code
rogueatbluechew.com all right we're
going to move on to topic two here the
star wars cassian andor series is coming
to disney plus
there's a sizzle reel that came out at
disney's investor day
they gave us a deeper behind-the-scenes
look at this series it's gonna follow
diego luna's character uh from rogue
one he was a rebel we believe fulcrum
agent uh it was kind of like an
espionage
series that was set up there on the
rings of caphrin
uh that could have been a whole series
we agree and now so did lucasfilm
it's going to be a 12 episode prequel
series 12 episodes is interesting means
they got a lot of story
to dive into we learned that amman
mothma is going back genevieve o'reilly
is coming back from rogue one she's
gonna be playing her role as the
political leader of the whole rebel
alliance
um i assume going to be the uh judy
dench
m2 diego luna's bond character right
what have you got yourself mixed into
again
um we got to see some concept art uh
showing cassie and endor and other
rebels looked like they were playing
some kind of mission to blow a dam
uh which i love because i don't know
about you guys the recent episode of the
mandalorian i thought
uh bill burr was going to wreck that
damn and flood that whole village
you can't blow up explosive crap on a
dam
and not have it gush water everywhere a
missed opportunity maybe they're saving
that visual for this cassian ender
series
also in the shot there is someone in an
imperial officer uniform standing right
there which maybe that's like a mole
they're gonna be like all right you're
you're gonna be pretending to be
imperial and you're gonna go in there
and he's like okay great
i this uniform must have a dead guy in
it so it kind of stinks
um but uh it also kind of shows maybe
this we're gonna see the very first time
someone posed as an imp to go behind uh
enemy lines which is something they do
in every star wars story now
um but this could have been the first
time it happens i would have fun and we
also get a shot of a star destroyer
being ripped apart
this the visuals that they are planning
for the show are
amazing um but i think what i'm most
curious about
are the ways it's gonna tie into what we
already know
so like we're watching the mandalorian
they have boba fett and ahsoka tano
showing up on there
there's going to be some connections in
crossover between this cassie and
andorra series and things we've already
seen
so from you guys i want to hear what
character storyline do you think from
the extended star wars universe
uh things like rebels or clone wars from
from rogue one the movie that's gonna
happen after this uh
the the prequel movies whatever how do
you think it's gonna tie into the
cassidy and andorra series
what is it gonna be how is it gonna
connect uh kristen what do you think
here's what i think i really think
that they are going to take a dark turn
with this series
um so a lot of our star wars world is
in this like place of like pj pg-13
where we all feel very comfortable and
everyone's included and it's great
but we haven't really had a like r
series that is star wars yet and this i
know i know go with me here maybe
it's not gonna happen but it's what i
want so we're gonna play with it okay
so um so we're going to get like this
like real
dark gritty series because in that like
big speech that he gives um
right before they go and they do like
everything that happens in rogue run
and um like all of that they have that
like
moment where he's backed up by all of
those people that are like we've done
some [ __ ] for the rebellion
like we have made some bad choices
and like at the end of this series like
i want
to question the validity of the
rebellion
i want to question why it happened and
like i want
i want everyone to be like oh my gosh
like who's really the right
side of this because of all the
decisions that they made but i think
that would be like really really
interesting and i would like to see that
and i think it'd be great to have those
characters all come
from like originally rogue one and be in
that series and like maybe he goes on a
couple of missions and we see those
people again
but like yeah that's what i want i want
a dark series i want a gritty series
and i want it now no yeah i mean
what you're describing kim uh kristin is
like exactly
what uh i think we all felt after rogue
one you know that kind of sense of uh
the fog of war mixed morality
um that like these people are terrorists
if you think about it i mean they're
terrorists
yeah with a good cause you know bringing
down space nazis
but the things they're doing like uh
cassie and endor in that scene on the
rings of kathrine he
he kills a guy or he gets a guy killed
and it's implied that he's done a lot of
that
uh so absolutely i want the series to
explore that darkness of a
the the rebel alliance aren't always
these uh shining uh
you know war heroes and these freedom
fighters they've done some dark things
in the name of that freedom so i think
that's definitely totally we'll explore
they're the good guys but like how how
good are they really
all right uh kristen i'll give you a
point for for that theory well done
um a whole point
um but uh kim kim i wanna hear from you
uh how do you think this is uh gonna
look what are what are
gonna be the the characters the
storylines from uh
from the other series we've seen that
tie in what specific characters are
story lines
so i was like nodding and pointing the
whole time when kristen was talking
because i think we're beating around the
same bush but
what i love about the mandalorian is
this real
exploration of good versus evil and how
those lines blur
and um in an improv class one of my
teachers
said there are no true villains and
there are no true heroes
and i want to see the exploration of
that
in the andor series through my boy
saw guerrera played by forrest whitaker
i want to see his beef with the alliance
i want to see
his extreme militant tactics i want to
see what breaks him like
what makes him toe this line because he
has got to be an antagonist i think
to cassian in in their in the alliance's
efforts in a big way
um and how how far will that antagonist
the role of his antagonist go i want to
see that
so bad it it's prime like it feels like
rogue one
well funny enough when i watched rogue
one i was so depressed at the end
because all i kept thinking was i'm
never gonna see these characters again
and i
love them so much and then the series
came out and i was like
hooray so of course naturally i'm like
you better bring my boy
saul guerrero back because clearly he
dies at the end of rogue one
not the end of rogue one but in rogue
one and um
i wanna see him i wanna see him crumble
i want him
i wanna see him go from what may have
been a hero
to now a villain yeah a villain or at
least a thorn in the paw of the whole
rebel alliance he's over there on jedha
now he's just uh leading that group and
uh they're kind of like taking things
their own way
um boy do i want to see borg gullet he
better bring that
i want to know more about that weird
squid thing that forces you to tell the
truth and tortures you
that was a thing that was a sex thing i
know it was a sex thing i want to know
what they were really using bor gullet
for because that's kristin maybe you'll
get your
r-rated this is your r-rated show that
we're going to get
this is what we want i want that too
sudden reading
if the hobbit can do it if the lord of
the rings can do it why not star wars
come on disney you know tony gilroy is
like we're not cutting
the borgulette stuff i know there's a
bunch of dicks on this thing but we're
leaving them
in you can't tell me to do it they're
like wait digs that brings it to nc17
he's like i know fine
add another dick it's like he's like a
referee in like a high school basketball
games like
give him another foul shot and another
one okay
put another dick in there you want to
keep going that's the third deck for you
anything about this dick we are adding
three more dicks
i'm with you or no it's like the the
small town judge that like
judge morty's like all right fine two
more dicks
the punishment this video brought to you
by blue
[Laughter]
all right ryan um uh bring us back to
sanity
what uh who do you think is gonna be oh
we'll we'll give two points by the way
for kim for uh bringing in
uh sauger over there um but uh ryan who
do you think
uh is gonna be the the other character
who ties in with this series
okay there's one character from clone
wars and rebels
every time they're ever on the screen it
just it makes the episode
they're a lot of fun i'm always like
anytime when rebels came out i was like
i really hate
really hope they go back and show this
character and that's hondo anaka
the pirate from clone wars i love hondo
he's the kind of guy who just loves
being bad he's always having a good time
he's a little bit of an anti-hero but
he's always like
angling for profit and we you know we
see him in clone wars he's still doing
fine then in rebels he's destitute we
never find out how
so i don't know exactly when this is
going to take place in a court like this
series is going to fall in the
timeline but i would love to see like
the downfall of hondo or him trying to
scrape his way back
because i think that these early days of
the rebel alliance like you're talking
about how they're basically terrorists
they're not necessarily going to be
enemies
with the huts and the gangsters and a
lot of times they're going to be using
them and that's going to like those
moral lines you guys are talking about
that's where those are going to come up
like okay we're going to use the huts
and these other gangsters to accomplish
but the ends justify the means
and then you can have hondo in there and
if you're going to take you know solo
into it we can see what happens to kira
if they can get amelia clark to come
back i mean i would like i don't think
they're going to make a solo sequel
so hondo can just lead the charge of all
these rogue characters
into into the the cassian source series
i would love that
yeah i love that uh yeah hondo is is
really cool
and like he is one of these uh figures
from the animated series it's like can
we please get this guy in live action
and yeah now we finally
have if it's if it's not if it's not
cassie and nandor series
it's gotta be kenobi you know we get him
in one of these two
uh and to tie kenobi solo thanks
kenobi yeah yeah the uh all that stuff
from solo i mean solo is such a weird
movie but man to get in crimson dawn to
potentially bring in
maul and kira in this that could be
really really cool i feel like maul
would be more likely to come up in the
kenobi series than casting endor which
is
dealing with stuff like you know weird
alliances you have to make which
hondo is like perfect for that man uh so
i'm gonna give you
uh two points too ryan i think that's a
that's a great
great great direction this could go but
uh we wanna hear from you guys let us
know in the comments below
uh what you wanna see this series being
um uh like do you want it to be more
james bond do you want it to be more
like jason bourne
espionage uh like how many people do you
want to see him kill how bloody do you
want to be do you want to be a hard
r probably not disney plus though it
does sound like disney is carving out a
little section on this platform
that could be for more mature content is
that where this is gonna go
uh uh what kind of missions what kind of
details left over from rebels and clone
wars do you wanna see uh comment down
below
all right now comes the time for our
rogue
questions uh other interesting headlines
that came out this week starting with
our man zack snyder he confirmed that
his justice league snyder cut is gonna
have an r
rating because batman drops an f-bomb
but what else is going to make this an
r-rated thing
what uh my question for you what is
going to be the most shocking r-rated
part
of the snyder cut dark side is going to
come out of a boom tube pick step and
wolf up rip them apart
and it's it's going to be very slow
motion very gory we're going to see the
tendons rip
we're going to see everything
steppenwolf ate for breakfast it's all
going to pour out
on the dark side like a baby's bib it's
going to be really gross
and not entertaining at all i feel like
i feel like the exact same thing's going
to happen only he's going to be
completely naked while he's doing this
he's like really going to make it that
like hard
r you know because like he's just
naked and like that was a choice that
snyder made and like everyone's going to
really enjoy it
but like that's what we're getting but
lots of little dicks on him
like the tentacle monster so many dicks
all right more attacks
not another dick kim what do you think
i'm gonna piggyback off of kristen i'm
hoping there's a nip slip
or a dick uh a dick shot
one or the other if ideally dick shot of
aquaman um but you know what i'll take
what i can get
just some of my dog like when he comes
out of the water he's gonna be like
coming up but he's not wearing those
pants it's just like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
or ideally there's just like a sea star
right over
his parts no i want a hard one it's so
big that it has gills
it's got its own gills yikes wow all
right
i gotta i have to move on after this
whole episode of road theory's getting
on our rating um well kids it's
mid-december so we gotta talk about
santa claus
um the og christmas superhero apologies
to jesus
if santa is the superhero of christmas
who is the super villain of christmas
and what are their
powers my instant thought is weather
the weather the villain of santa claus
is
weather like snow
in particular is like a pain in the butt
like he's like used to it he's used to
it because he's always like at the north
pole
but that doesn't make it any easier when
he's like delivering presents
so like the weather is just his like
mortal enemy
the foe of all foes because i mean also
like he's in a sleigh and
it does look like a warm coat but when
it's like real real cold up there like
no thank you so frostbite snow
got it i'm gonna go with labor
[Music]
you unions about it he i mean you know
various mythologies
have gone into this and the elves are
always real happy
to be doing their jobs some of them you
know like the one in rudolph wants to
have another job
but it does seem like a lot of work just
for the you know
the joy of the work itself but not just
the elves but also the reindeer
who basically are raised up for you know
years and
they most of them don't get to make it
to the show you know and they're
probably saying
can't we rotate in and out why has it
got to be donder and donner and blitzen
every year
can't like just give someone else a
chance for once
yeah it's a very oligarchical capitalist
system at the north pole and i really
think there's probably
some kind of uh rebellion fermenting
there um
yeah if a lot of water is uh if if
marx's communist manifesto had
illustration
the image of the bourgeois uh a factory
owner would be santa claus
uh yeah i mean think about it he's like
the guy who's running the non-profit
who's acting like oh i'm getting i'm
doing something nice
for the kids of the world but he
actually doesn't really pay
his employer employees that much and uh
and why is it that the richer kids of
the world get nicer presents
and the poorer kids barely get anything
like that he says something wrong that's
one percent it reinforces the class
system that's a great point uh there's
no other explanation i can think of
um kim uh what do you think okay
santa's arch enemy
is a guy that you may have heard of
called
terence claus who's terence claus
terence claus is the slighted younger
brother of the cause family
who always hoped one day to grow up to
be
the santa claus but unfortunately his
older brother
nicholas had always was always going to
be the destined one
so terence is just very angry and mad
and wants to you know he's kind of like
a loki he wants to like
just get his vengeance upon the world
and um and you know he has no logical
sense to why he's evil except
to get back at his brother his big
brother nicholas
um for taking his spot what he believes
is his rightful spot
as the santa claus so taryn's claws
look out for look out for him
[Laughter]
hamlet yeah that's so shakespearean
absolutely
i'm seeing a game of thrones thrown but
made out of candy canes
yes yeah i mean we realized a thousand
percent santa claus
super villain would be the night king
from game of thrones would he not
i think that seems like an apt super
villain
for him we're in the same universe
terence is
the night king oh i see it i got it i
got it
you find that out later on in the series
oh spoiler geez
well uh i'm gonna give the point for uh
the true answer which is
labor unions uh because we gotta
remember who the real enemy is
uh and it is capitalism ryanairy you are
our winner of this episode of rogue
theory well done sir
but a big thank you to all of our guests
here uh ryan airy
kim trung kristen sanchez follow all of
them on their respective social medias
it's been a wonderful episode going deep
into the star wars universe with you
guys
uh don't forget to subscribe to the
rogue theory podcast feed
um so that you can get early episodes of
all this stuff stay tuned to the new
rockstars youtube channel for this and
other shows
follow me at ea boss follow new
rockstars on all social media
and yeah subscribe to us here at new
rockstars and we'll see you next time
everyone stay safe out there
bye and
tax the millionaires and billionaires
sex the rich
tax
[Music]
you